Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so it's a really
sad day.
Carrie Fisher passed away.
So just wanted to remember her and talk a
little bit about her role in the Star Wars
universe and what might be happening in the
future, especially a Princess Leia spinoff
movie, so here we go is the saddest thing
ever that she passed away but she had such
a big impact on the Star Wars franchise in
ways that you didn't necessarily see from
her being on camera, she had a big role in
being a script doctor behind the scenes like
she would rewrite a lot of Leia's dialogue
that she felt wasn't quite as good as it could
be.
She eventually became a screenwriter herself.
She released books about mental health and
her time in Hollywood, so there's a lot out
there if you want to learn about Carrie Fisher
in real life like she talked a lot about her
life growing up in the spotlight because her
mother, Debbie Reynolds was a long time film
actor.
So for better or worse.
She grew up in the Hollywood limelight.
But within the context of Star Wars for those
you asking yes they did wrap production on
Star Wars episode eight.
So whatever her role was going to be in that
movie, whatever, Princess Leia story was that's
going to be unaffected they've already shot
her scenes.
They did say that she was going to be a much
bigger part of the story than she was an episode
seven, so whatever she's doing with the resistance
it's gonna be a much bigger deal now now that
they been cut off from the Galactic Republic.
Remember the first order blew up what remained
of the new Galactic Republic.
So essentially the resistance is a much smaller
force than the rebellion like even smaller
than the rebellion was and whatever the action
and plot of her storyline.
It'll probably have something to do with Poe
and Finn's characters they've also expanded
Poe's character because Poe Dameron was a
relatively minor character in the episode
seven script.
But then Oscar Isaac just so fantastic on
set the JJ Abrams was convinced to put more
scenes and for him.
He was originally going to kill Poe off earlier
in the film, but I was like only got Oscar
Isaac fantastic.
I love what he's doing so were going to keep
him on.
So in the way that the original trilogy characters
like Luke and Leah were important part of
episode seven, but relatively minor, just
because they spent most of the film setting
up the new characters.
Now that they've done that they can be a much
bigger part of the story without overshadowing
the new characters so a lot more Princess
Leia in episode eight leading the resistance
against the first-order which is to bring
it back around the Star Wars Rogue one.
So now that were doing other stories inside
the Star Wars universe that feature original
trilogy things without necessarily retelling
the same stories that we've already seen the
time is right for them to start planning for
a young Princess Leia movie one of the minor
complaints from Rogue one was that Peter Princess
Leia, we know her impact in the Star Wars
universe how important she was in the Galactic
Senate the fight against the Emperor.
But that doesn't really come across during
Rogue one, you don't really see that like
they just relay past baton style the death
Star plans to her as she juts away in the
Crilly Corvette to the opening moments of
Star Wars episode four, but she was a huge
figure or the rebellion leading up to that
she was the youngest person in the history
of the galaxy to ever become a member of the
Galactic Senate.
So there's just so much about her life.
They have not told on screen.
It just right for spinoff movie territory
like younger teenage Leah leading up to the
moments when she joined the Galactic Senate.
So she joined when she was around 16 years
old.
So some of the expanded universe novels which
technically are canon anymore have already
dealt with some of her childhood insight really
small off ended ways like some of the smaller
novels like the Scholastic books like if you
been reading the Star Wars comic book since
they started publishing at Marvel again that
mostly picks up at the end of episode four.
So they been telling a lot of extra new Leah
stories that sort of fill in the gaps between
the movies but that's mostly Leia of the future.
It involves people like Harrison Ford that
don't necessarily want to come back to do
more movies we have the younger Han Solo movie.
It would make sense that instead of doing
Leah between the original trilogy movies.
You do a coming-of-age story that would focus
more on her and her adventures before she
joined the Galactic Senate, so she's force
sensitive.
Just like Luke was but she didn't display
a quite as openly as he did.
So if you remember the way they treated the
force during Rogue one Donnie Yen's character
believes in the force.
He has a Kaibur crystal inside his staff.
He invokes it in a way that does not involve
light sabers or Jedi, he just believes in
the force and keeps chanting, I am one with
the force the forces with me so you could
tell up Princess Leia story that involves
the force in that way without her ever having
to build a light saber and if you watch stranger
things Millie Bobby Brown is a dead ringer
for a young Carrie Fisher she could totally
pull it off.
She kinda has that quiet grace about her that
you would imagine a young Princess Leia would
have that she has a lot of sassing her to
like you watch Empire strikes back, it probably
had some of my favorite funny sassy Princess
Leia scenes in that movie were she just does
not give a shit about it she's not taking
anybody's crap in my mind, why you follow
goodbye kiss.
I can arrange that.
So, were they to do a young Princess Leia
movie.
When would you wanted to be set in what kind
of stories would you want them to tell because
they could treat the original trilogy elements
the same way they did Rogue one Darth Vader
could be a part of the story in a small way
she didn't interact with Vader a lot as a
child like Bail Organa was totally in on this
conspiracy went Obi wan and Yoda cooked it
up working to separate the children will keep
them as far away from the Emperor Vader as
possible.
Growing up hidden safe.
Children must be kept we must take them somewhere
with the Cisco nonsense that presents should
be my wife said I will take the girl we've
always talked of adopting a baby girl.
She will be loved.
So while she did cross paths with Vader as
she got older.
It was just in the same way that the Rogue
one characters bumped into Darth Vader, but
just very briefly very offhandedly.
So Darth Vader's off trying to finish the
purge trying to bring the galaxy to heal wall
Leia is growing up on all the ranches trying
to live a normal childhood with her parents
like right now Millie Bobby Brown is about
12 years old in real life if they were to
do a Princess Leia movie after episode nine
and say like three or four years.
She would be the perfect age for an adolescent
Leah before we see her at the end of Rogue
one just like leading up to that moment when
she gets the death Star plans.
So I will say you know what I hope they do
is go because, Princess Leia will always be
a big figure in Star Wars going forward regardless
of how they choose to use her.
I just I hope they don't use a CG Leah I just
feel like it would be a betrayal of her memory
if they just started stuffing in CG Leah all
the time like hopefully this Rogue one CG.
Leah was a very one-off type of thing like
we could flashback to her as a child, but
I'd rather see them do it in a more real way
like you know you cast someone like Millie
Bobby Brown and that's how you do young Leia
scenes which is because this new trilogy,
the working on episode eight episode nine
is a Skywalker trilogy I would totally be
okay if they had like a brief CG Leah moment
at the very end of that.
Not that that's what they're going to do.
I'm just saying that if they want to use a
little bit of Leia to bookend Kylo Ren story
at the end of episode nine.
I would be okay with it, then let me know
in the comments how would you want them to
continue to use Carrie Fisher's Princess Leia
in Star Wars going forward not feel like were
all the same page.
We don't want the grandma off target and treatment
like it just almost be a perversion of her
memory and when I say forward.
I mean forward in the timeline now obviously
if they choose to do young Princess Leia that
though definitely have to recast someone else
but what if they want to use a dolt Princess
Leia.
Would you rather see the CG version that we
saw during Rogue one or would you just rather
have them recast the role like we see Princess
Leia in another 10 years, although I don't
think that's going to happen I think what
they're going to do after episode nine is
that they'll find other characters to follow
like if the gonna do a new saga then they'll
find other characters besides the skywalkers
so you're freaking out about them just stuffing
CG Leah into everything.
Don't worry about that like the neck in a
pervert her memory.
Kathleen Kennedy would probably be the first
person to put the kibosh on something like
that.
So what I think we'll see the future.
Is that they'll just remember her you might
see them cut in images from previous movies
and hopefully will get a chance to see some
young Princess Leia in a spinoff movie.
But that's not can happen anytime soon.
Like they have this Han Solo movie.
There might be some young Princess Leia in
that but she didn't really run into Han Solo.
During his younger years that much so we'll
see how it goes down but I just cannot wait
for 2017 to get here.
I'm so ready for the dumpster fire that is
2016 to just end.
So may he rest in peace Carrie Fisher we will
remember you forever, but what can happen
next is is because Sherlock season four is
getting ready to start.
I didn't explainer video that just explains
what's happened so far just to get you guys
ready because I'm in be doing episode videos
for Sherlock.
So that will post in the morning and I'll
post some more marvel some flash season three,
so the be bunch more comic book stuff coming,
in addition to Sherlock while you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for my
Darth Vader Rogue one video and you can click
here for all my Easter eggs that you so much
for watching, and may the force be with you
guys tonight